on vient tous
[Musique]
nous sommes deux ans en arrière
je suis assise dans un avion j'aperçois
par le hublot un morceau de ma
destination
là bas je vais vivre une expérience qui
va changer ma vie et aujourd'hui j'ai 6
po je suis ici pour vous donner trois
conseils qui vont peut-être changer la
vôtre ou pas restons modestes à 6 ans
cet avion je réalise que je me suis
embarqué dans une vraie aventure une
prise de risque et le premier conseil
que je voudrais vous donner et que j'ai
expérimenté avant même de monter dans
cet avion est la capacité à assumer ses
choix jusqu'au bout et plus globalement
la confiance en soi
en effet une fois mon dut en poche j'ai
opté pour une école d'ingénieur en
alternance
la première année est passé puis la
deuxième est arrivé l'ennui avec un
ennui profond qui m'a transformé en
zombie qui m'a vidé de ma passion pour
l'industrie qui me motive et un an des
luttes et la troisième année arriver
j'allais devoir passer six mois dans une
école et 6 mois en entreprise
on nous a présenté les choix pour
erasmus et c'est en parcourant les
listes que mon intérêt est né
j'avais trouvé quelque chose qui avait
réussi a piqué ma curiosité qui m'avait
sorti de mon hibernation et sans savoir
pourquoi j'ai jeté mon dévolu sur un mot
un mot qui m'a donné envie tu m'as fait
rêver et qui représentait un défi à lui
tout seul
istanbul je n'avais aucune idée de se
trouver sans mot sur une carte
quelle langue on parlait peut-être qu'on
y mange ai aucune idée
mais c'est à ce moment là où j'ai décidé
de partir étudier dans une université
les plus prestigieux d'istanbul que j'ai
réalisé que le plusieurs ce ne serait
pas de prononcer le nom du responsable
turc du pur erasmus mais bien d'arriver
à assumer mon choix jusqu'au bout autant
à l'école que face à mes collègues de
travail parce que au début j'avais droit
à toutes sortes de l'encouragement du
genre tu ne devra pas
tu devrais avoir peur d'y aller et tous
ces supers encouragements lehmann est
souvent de personnes qui étaient passés
maîtres dans l'art de rester dans leur
zone de confort deux mois avant mon
départ
l'instabilité du pays complique les
choses
maintenant même mon école hésitent à
faire partir mais moi j'y crois c'est ma
porte de sortie c'est devenu mon projet
et je suis parti vivre pays des loukoums
parce que la zone de confort c'est bien
mon art armes ont dû des compétences
incroyable se développer au fond son
canapé sur netflix à cette étape
ma qualité confiance en moi était au top
seul contre tous je partais mais le
trouillomètre augmenter au fur et à
mesure que la distance entre moi
istanbul diminuer mon deuxième conseil
est sociabilisés ouvrez vous car on ne
s'améliore et on ne réussit jamais seul
clairement pour moi survivre dans une
ville de 10 millions d'habitants dont je
ne connaissais ni la langue ni
l'organisation allait être un petit peu
compliqué sans quelque soutien
j'étais donc décidé à m'ouvrir aux
autres à une nouvelle culture et
potentiellement à me faire de nouveaux
amis ma première sauveuse a été ma
colocataire
elle m'a fourni un toit et m'a expliqué
comment me nourrir et trouver de l'eau
dans une ville où l'eau courante n'est
pas potable
elle aurait pu rester une simple ami
mais je crois que nous avons partagé
bien plus dur en ce samedi pluvieux à
regarder netflix en anglais sous-titré
turcs nous sommes échangés une vision du
monde et sommes devenus amis mes autres
sauveteurs dans cette mer agitée
d'istanbul ont été les autres étudiants
erasmus y turc
j'ai rencontré des gens venus de toutes
origines de toutes cultures d'autres
cultures
avec eux j'ai parcouru la cappadoce
essais montgolfière hommes ont calé et
ses sources et nos liens se sont
renforcés
certains de ses biens sont encore très
présents malgré la distance me rend plus
fort chaque jour comme une équipe de
supporters
cette équipe de l'ombre que nous avons
tous au fond de nous qui nous rend plus
fort chaque jour qui nous a aidé à
surmonter toutes les épreuves constitué
de notre famille de nos amis est
indispensable
mon troisième conseil simple travailler
et ne travaillez pas juste sur le sujet
qui vous intéresse et qui vous rapporte
directement
intéressez-vous aux opportunités annexe
les bonus car ce sont les bonus qui font
la différence à istanbul je n'ai jamais
autant travaillé de ma vie car je savais
que l'échec était inenvisageable
si j'échoue s était de retour en début
de 3e année il a c'était hors de
question il me fallait ce diplôme alors
j'ai travaillé encore plus et j'ai parlé
anglais grâce à ça aujourd'hui je me
sens capable de parler anglais en public
grâce à ça je me sens capable d'intégrer
n'importe quelle entreprise l'équipe de
travail grâce à ça j'ai rédigé des
rédigé une thèse sur un thème en anglais
très tordu
grâce à ça je ne sens plus fort
techniquement tout simplement le poids
des mots anglais courant sur mon cv n'a
plus le même poids lorsque je suis
rentré je suis passé de istanbul
mégalopole de 18 millions d'habitants
à annonay en ardèche le choix qui a été
heureux de croyez moi mais je ne suis
pas rester à attendre que l'année se
termine pour contrebalancer je me suis
inscrite à un concours de créativité
logistique le concept était simple 24
heures pour créer un projet de toutes
pièces avec des inconnus affirmations de
saisie des collations équipe et travail
intense les trois facteurs de réussite
étaient réunis et nous avons gagné
quand vous lancer dans un projet qu'ils
soient étudiants ou professionnels ne
vous intéressez pas juste au sujet qui
vous intéresse vous pouvez faire le
minimum vital y avoir quand même votre
diplôme le résultat escompté mais vous
serez passer à côté de tous les bonus et
à diplôme égal un employé sera choisi
plutôt qu'un autre
surtout les bonus les expériences
annexes c'est pourquoi il est important
de prendre chaque opportunité pour être
maître de sa formation à travers cette
expérience j'ai pu travailler sur ma
confiance en moi
en ouverture aux autres et ma capacité
de travail j'ai ainsi pu maximiser mes
chances de construire comme je
souhaitais ma vie après une grande étape
les études à la fin de chaque cycle
il est nécessaire de rebondir et se
lancer un défi
c'est une très bonne idée pour avoir de
nouveau challenge et développer ses
compétences alors aimez vous ouvrez vous
ai travaillé à vous créez votre vie de
rêve
[Applaudissements]